this is Jocko podcast number 120 with
echo Charles and me Jocko Willick good
evening echo good evening so it's been a
while since QA yeah so we have some QA
from the interwebs yeah go first
question Jocko more than once on the
podcast you've mentioned how the teams
were so competitive that no one wanted
to admit when they were cold being took
to cold puts you at a tactical
disadvantage in hindsight was that a
failure to control your ego so your ego
doesn't control you I didn't ask this
question out of idle curiosity a lot of
folks on active duty listen to the
podcast and I'm concerned they might put
themselves their teammates and their
mission in jeopardy because of their
egos won't let them admit they're too
hot or too cold
alright so good question good point and
there's definitely a big difference
between between being uncomfortably cold
right like unlike you're just
uncomfortably cold or uncomfortably hot
or uncomfortably thirsty or hungry or
whatever and being in an actual state
where you're putting the mission in
jeopardy because you're too cold or hot
or thirsty or whatever so I just needed
to say this in the team's you are 95% of
the time you are cold too cold too hot
too wet too thirsty too miserable
something there's no ton when you're in
the field you put on a hundred pounds
worth of gear at worth of gear you're
uncomfortable from the word go from the
word go and you're cold you know you
come in over the beach you're in wet
camis it doesn't matter you come out
with great technology and we got a dry
suit of this we got a wet suit that no
you're you're miserable it's not you're
gonna be cold you're gonna be
uncomfortable you ride in a zodiac first
you you ride in a in a big rib which is
like a 10 meter boat and you have your
zodiacs on that boat so you're in that
boat you're getting sprayed with water
you're getting bounced up and down you
do that for three hours
and then you launch your little boats
into the water well while you're doing
that you fall in the water or you slip
you get sprayed more you're covered in
water by the way the waters not warm and
then you got a because you're gonna
travel then 15 knots so you got a fear
facing a 15 not headwind for another two
hours in a Zodiac and then you're gonna
get the water and swim oh you're gonna
be cold that's just the way it is and
you can't complain about that so and you
don't complain about it in the teams you
just keep your mouth shut
that's what you do keep your mouth shut
now the big distinction here is this is
correct if you're gonna get hypothermia
or you're gonna get a heatstroke or
you're gonna go down from dehydration
then yeah you got to speak up and B you
gotta say hey guess what I got an issue
here I'm I'm starting my you know I'm
starting to get dizzy or sorta get
lightheaded or whatever yeah if you
cross the line to where it goes from
discomfort to actual problem then you
definitely need to speak up and it does
happen it happens a lot actually you
know when we when we do our land warfare
training in the desert in the summertime
it's a 120 degree heat god you're gonna
take heat casualties you know when I was
running training we used to just have
premeditated heat casualty evacuation
because we knew someone was gonna go
down that's just the way it's gonna
happen cuz you got 40 guys that are all
turning and burning and they're all
running on three or four hours of sleep
and then they're going out in the field
and they just got back from the field
and there's no time to rehydrate you
know okay there's time but some guys
might forget to rehydrate and next thing
you know you got a guy going down so
this stuff does happen and yeah you got
to let your team know what's going on
I've the the closest call I had I was on
a long patrol training patrol in the
Ozark Mountains of Arkansas whose
summertime was hot we were planning to
pump water meaning you bring a little
water filtration system into the field
and you get to a stream and you can fill
your canteens and it's great and it
seems like you have water forever
because their streams well we the way
the patrol went we started off in pairs
and then we linked up with fire team and
they make up
you look up with a platoon well while we
were in the squad link-up we for
whatever reason the course that I was on
I didn't hit water we had a couple
streams that were supposed to be there
and they weren't because they're
intermittent streams so sometimes
streams aren't running year-round and
the time of year it was the streams
weren't running so the first one I was
okay I'll be okay
got to the so you'll up over a mountain
come back down the other side get to
this where the stream is marked
intermittent stream is marked on a map
guess what no stream so then by that
time I was out of water so now coming
that the next day I said to myself you
know if there's not water off this next
stream I'm gonna have issues and there
wasn't water the next day so yeah that's
but I started to feel the dehydration
coming on me that's why I hate being
thirsty yeah I always carry as much
water as I can you you got to be
paranoid about being thirsty once you
start going down from a dehydration it's
really a bad situation you went the
whole day no it was two days yeah I
don't know I had water going in but I
really I didn't have a ton of water I
should have had I should have had one oh
I should had maybe two more liters of
water as a as a just-in-case
but I didn't you gotta carry yeah yeah
cuz you gotta carry it now you're
heavier now you're sweating more so
there's a little balance you gotta
figure yeah yeah but yeah it can't be a
problem yes I have seen it become a
problem where we're guys egos too big
they don't want to admit it for sure so
yes this is a good warning don't let
your ego get you in real trouble and
because that's gonna hurt your platoon
even more mm-hmm so don't let that
happen
don't let your ego prevent you from
telling the truth about what's happening
and this happens in this can happen in
the business world to where oh you know
what
oh I don't really know how to operate
this piece of equipment but I'm not
gonna say anything I'm just gonna try
and do it well that's how someone gets
hurt so again that's an ego problem when
you have an issue when you know you
can't do something you've never done
something before step up and and raise
your hand now of course you should have
done the research you should have you
know you should have figured some stuff
out on your own but if you fail to do
that don't dig the hole deeper yeah
raise your hand say what the problem was
there you go good question yeah make
sense cuz that especially the thirst
thing like the dehydration thing yeah
you don't want to be the guy saying oh
I'm thirsty you here's the thing I think
nowadays though like teams and coaches
here's the thing in football case so Pop
Warner football they'd be like yeah no
water you know we have a water break you
drink water at the water break otherwise
you're practicing you know kind of thing
it's like a toughen you up thing but man
that can jam your health up yeah but
let's face it I mean it would be pretty
rare you know if you gave people that if
you're doing a practice what how long is
the practice lasts two hours two hours
okay
bro you can make it two hours if you're
properly hydrated now if a person is not
properly hydrated going into the
practice sure that can that can be a
problem but if someone is properly
hydrated going into the situation it
should not be a problem and I'll tell
you what if you are in the military and
you're going to the field man pre
hydrate like Chris that used to save me
so much from carrying so much water and
just drink so much water now tell you
where the problem comes in you're in a
helicopter ride for an hour and a half
you gotta piss so bad it's awful well
you know what bring a little bring a
little plastic bottle with you so you
can piss in the bottle it's way less of
an issue I think like finding a place to
drink versus Foley for sure it's way too
clear they have to yeah if you pre
hydrate properly no matter how hard
you're working you can go like 12 hours
without any water which is pretty legit
yeah for you you know kind of an average
seal mission twelve hours get your
brilliant plenty of time yeah yeah but
Kia I mean I'm talking pot warning here
so you know but here's the weird thing
like when you went to high school
college
they'd have water right there right
there in the sideline and they'd you
know they're really aware of good you
need water drink more water well I think
that was also the time yeah that's not
the actually the point the era the era
right like so when we were kids no one
ever ever one single time a mile from
the time I was zero until I was 18
yeah no one ever said to me hey make
sure you drink water yeah never never
heard anyone say that it was like oh
you're thirsty drink a coke what you
yes the way it was you know so that
changed for you in that time period yeah
when I got to when I got to seal
training when I got a buds that's when
they were saying oh you gotta stay
hydrated yeah I thought it was kind of a
joke I thought they were getting here
first time I'll hide you mean drink
water what do you mean why would you
call it something else hydrated yeah
like it's like this maybe well you
should because you can go down from like
heat K this like keep for there's heat
exhaustion heat stroke heat exhaustion
yeah and there's all kinds of heat
injuries you can get yeah and you get
heat stroke right you can straight up
die oh yeah so that's not you know it's
not a matter of like oh yeah tough it
out right you can't tough it out you're
shutting down kind of thing that's for
sure it's so you know that is important
for the heat thing and I guess that is
and that's good you know going back to
this question that is probably why we
would see heat casualties in training
because guys do not want to say anything
they like my mother to say anything yeah
I'm not gonna get it on yeah look even
worse that's what happened you could
stuck with an IV now you're laying in
the field everyone else by the way
continues on doing another tit lammeter
hump to a target and you're sitting
there laid up in the ambulance like a
little baby no one wants that but a
pretty high if you pre hydrate properly
you won't be in that situation yeah but
if you are gonna get that situation you
need to say something yeah we're talking
about your life yeah essentially and
more important we're talking about the
mission yeah yeah I'm still thinking
about the pot we're in a situation but
yeah man I dig it and you are correct I
can't help but agree with you 100%
that question Jocko dear Jocko my chosen
community has lost and continues to lose
members due to suicide one reason is
that they don't ask for help I think one
reason they don't ask for help is that
they're afraid of being or being seen as
weak I'm aware that this takes strength
and discipline to be able to perceive
when you need help and to ask for it I
don't know how to convey that to them
could you address how one can gather
support from their team without losing
face
so so there's an obvious reason why I
paired these two questions together
because they're both very very similar
and it's the same thing and if we don't
if a member of your team won't come
forward and admit they have an issue
then the issue is not gonna get
addressed and this is the same exact
thing they have to explain to your team
like hey if you start going down because
you're dehydrated or you start getting D
getting frostbite and you need to get
warmed up you need to say something if
you don't say something that's gonna
hurt the whole team that's what's bad so
so I think that's important I think
that's important to make sure everyone
understands that this part of being a
good operator is knowing your
limitations and when you reach your
limitations raising your hand and saying
hey this is a problem and believe me
there's there's guys that might complain
about little things and they're
eventually gonna be labeled as a little
complainer right and they don't really
have issues so there's a fine line right
there's a fine line but for this one you
know for someone that's having some kind
of mental stress well again we got to
recognize what's going on we got to
recognize that it's impacting us
negatively at work so that means you got
to raise your hand if it's having a
negative impact on the way of performing
then you got to raise your hand and I
think it's important to explain to
people that this is something that
something that happens to could happen
ever anybody and it's not a negative
thing it's just a reality it's it's kind
of like it reminds me of being afraid
right and if if if you let's say you got
a new guy that's never done anything
before and he doesn't know that he's
gonna be afraid going on an operation
then he's gonna wonder why his stomach
is upset
or why he's second-guessing themselves
or why he can't sleep like oh you can't
sleep guess what that's normal
you're going on a hardcore combat
operation tomorrow the fact that you
can't sleep is completely normal
the fact that you feel sick to your
stomach is completely normal the fact
that you're you're shaking that those
things are normal like you're gonna feel
those that's okay it's not that big of a
deal and those things are just
that's what they are and if you know
what they are and you know that fear is
okay and it's acceptable and it's
actually kind of good right because if
if you're not feeling any fear
whatsoever all then you know you've got
some well that you should be feeling
afraid you should be if you'd feel fear
that should that should propel you to
get you on edge those all those things
are actually happening for a reason so
there's nothing wrong with that and I
think that's the same thing that you
gotta explain to people with stress like
okay that you can have too much fear you
keep someone at that heightened state
for an extended period of time
well that's called combat stress and
it's real and it can happen it can
happen anyone and you know how many
books have we talked about on this
podcast where you can see stress combat
stress taking its toll on people and and
when it does you know we've talked about
it many times P if you if you get to
that point you need a break and and dick
winners from Band of Brothers you know
he would give those guys breaks without
them even knowing that he was giving him
a break he's saying hey echo you got to
go back and do a little logistics run
for four days just make sure we have
more supplies coming our way get you off
the frontline get you a breather
so that way again the same metaphor I've
used before us if you have an engine in
the red and you keep running it what's
gonna happen the engine it's gonna burn
out it's not gonna be usable if you have
someone that's psychologically stressed
and they're in the red and you keep
running them in the red guess what
eventually they're not gonna be usable
anymore so you need to give them a break
get them off the line because if you do
take an engine if your engine like check
engine light comes on and you go and get
it maintained get it fixed the engines
still good if you keep running it the
engine will be destroyed so you got to
do that with your people and you've got
to make sure everybody knows and I think
that's a real simple metaphor to use
with people as well say look we're
running hard and we're gonna put some
stress on the engine and if you don't
keep the engine maintained the engines
gonna braking you won't be any good to
the team you won't be good for the
mission so if you start feeling your
engine light go on you gotta let someone
know so we can give you the proper
maintenance and that's it Jody medic
talked about that too Jody was you know
saying hey you know basically if you get
injured if you break your ankle
they don't just expect you just to keep
going no
like okay you need to get back and you
needed to rehab well the same thing had
happened to your brain your brain gets a
break in it you don't just keep driving
her it's gonna fracture and fall apart
what do you do you you take a break you
get down time and you get recovered and
then you'll be ready to rock and roll
again so two really good questions to
start it off you know again especially
for folks out there on the battlefield
and then it's not just for people on the
battlefield because it happens with any
any group of people that are in a
stressful environment I mean obviously
cops get put into a really stressful
environment all the time well if you
need to take a breather you need to say
something before you before you burn out
the engine yeah
same thing with business world right
people in the business world get
extremely stressed out well you probably
need a break at some point yeah make
sure you work that in there don't like
like police have like a like a mandatory
program or a mandatory situation where
you know you go through I think we're
like when they shoot someone or
something like that like mandatory you
have to go to like some kind of like
counseling yeah most of them do now yeah
yeah so that that makes sense too
because even if let's say you don't
necessarily need it or whatever right
you go through a shooting situation you
got to go mandatory and then I gotta go
through but it's good that everyone kind
of does it because it seems like oh it
takes away the the negative yeah you
know like I know like oh I'm the only
guy you know I'm the only guy that
apparently feels this way I'm looking
around no one else is going to
counseling yeah now I'm the only guy I
must be the weak guy so I don't know
they've done that somewhat in the
military of hey when you come home from
deployment everyone's gonna go talk to
uh talk to what is it a psychotherapist
or something like psychologists the kind
to do that I know they did that in the
SEAL Teams where they'd be everyone
would go they didn't do while I was in
they give you like a piece of paper to
fill out which everyone just got to
conduct pencil whip I don't know what
just like you know fill it out except
for Tony
you know what Tony wrote on the head of
his what he wrote
this is a cry for help it was pretty
funny but anyways that was he filled out
like a whole fake one about just a funny
one yeah but it makes sense though
because of that because that's kind of
yeah that's really do you think it's the
smart way to do things let's give
everyone a let's give everyone a
baseline sort of okay check here you go
yeah and that way no one's no one has to
go no one has to take raise their hand
first right now you're all gonna talk to
somebody I think it's a smart thing to
do yeah it kind of goes along with the
earlier question to like if it's a water
break and hey guys water break
everyone's drinking water so now it's
like you don't have to feel like the one
plus oh yeah you know kind of thing oh
yeah like that's the exact same thing
yeah so yeah if you got an issue man
speak up let everyone know you know that
way you can do your job you can do it
longer you can do it better your goal is
to do the is to be the best possible
that you be the best possible capability
so that you can go out and do your job
the best if you if you've got issues
you've got to say something so that you
can keep doing your job for the team
yeah it's like gum like don't look at
yourself as being weak look at yourself
is trying to optimize your strength kind
of joke you know maybe just flip over
the way you look look there it is next
question do you think martial arts
tournaments are the most effective way
for preparing for physical confrontation
I just competed my first my second
jujitsu tournament as a three straight
white belt and in one match I completely
lost focus and control of my mind
because I believe I was taken aback by
the strength and wildness of my opponent
a man I dig it hundred percent I barely
I can barely even remember how the match
unfolded I've given this match
significant thought and I concluded that
I need to compete more I'm very calm I'm
very comfortable with everyone in my
Academy I trusted as I roll with without
question they're like family now
the
I the guy in the tournament was a total
stranger he was unknown and therefore
elicited fear I allowed myself to be to
be crippled by fear is there any other
way to overcome this beyond competing in
tournaments thank you all right you know
competing is definitely part of it and
in it's interesting that he's asking if
this is the most effective way to
prepare for a physical confrontation it
is a very good way to prepare for a
physical confrontation and then the
bottom line is competing one of the
things that competing one of the things
that that's true with competing and it's
true with anything is that the more
familiar you are with the unfamiliar the
more familiar it will become I know that
sounds pretty obvious but the more
familiar you are with the unfamiliar the
more familiar it will become so you get
to become familiar with things that are
unfamiliar and you learn how to handle
things that you aren't expecting in the
teams we always talked about that your
first freefall jump when you're when you
learn how to skydive with with a
freefall rig and your first jump seems
like it's it's like three seconds long
even though it's a minute even though
it's a minute because you're just you're
all amped up and you all you see is your
altimeter and the more you jump the more
you see until that minute I mean think
of have you ever have tried to hold your
breath for a minute yes that that's like
a long time right but and that's that's
the amount of time that can take up a
freefall can be a nice a long minute
where you're observing all these
different things when you first start
doing it it doesn't seem very long I'm
sure if we had Andy you know Andy stump
on here his 1-minute freefall price
seems like a really really long time
because he's got thousands of of jumps
and so this is the same thing the the
more you train for chaos the more
accustomed you're going to become to the
chaos now what's great is in this
particular case you talk about this
guy's just wild and crazy and hey if you
survive it that first time well the next
time someone goes wild and crazy like
okay well here's what I need to do you
with us in check I need to I need to
hold on I need to make sure you don't
give any positions but I'm not gonna get
crazy I'm just gonna absorb some you you
go through that mental drill and the
more you go through that mental drill
the battle you better you will get at it
and this is true this is true with
anything and and that's why you know
when I was running the SEAL training we
put the we would make it so we'd hit
people with the most random possible
things because that's what prepares you
for and impossible things is random
possible things that's what you want to
deal with it's kind of weird you know in
jujitsu Dean Dean used to talk about
this and now you can hear John Danaher
talking about it as well and if if you
have never been in a certain situation
before you're not ready for it
and when okay so there's a there's a
position in in jujitsu called 50/50
right that's what it's called now we
used to call it Kakariko because that's
the position that Dean was in when he
beat a guy named Kakariko for the ATCC
World Championships and Dean Dean calls
that position ninety ten because he's
been in it so much that even though it's
a neutral position meaning we both have
the same advantages and disadvantages
when Dean's in that position he's been
in it so much that he's got a 90% chance
he's got a 90% chance to success because
he's been there 10 times 20 times 30
times more than you and I heard John
Danaher talking about the same thing the
other day he's getting pee you know his
his jiu-jitsu fighters right now are
doing things to guys that are they're
putting people in positions that the
person's not used to so if you're not
used to it guess what your advantage
even though I might have trained even
though let's say I'm a jujitsu black
belt and I've been training for 20 years
if I've never been in this particular
position before it's I might as well be
a white belt now you can see that
happening you can see that happening in
jujitsu that's why when somebody comes
up with a new new type of moves that
move can be effective for a little while
like let's say let's say you came up
with a new move you might catch me in
that a new move one time and then I go
oh I know what he did but if but now if
instead of just a new move you had a
whole new area
yeah that I has alone oh yeah then I had
to learn a whole new deal around it's
the same thing with Eddie Bravo and
intense planet you know like they they
were doing things like oh I've never
been in this position before now what do
I do
yeah and they were catching guys like
that and then them four more people
figure out that part of that system okay
well then you get better at it and we
get to a neutral ground again but
anytime you can so in training anytime
you can get to be put yourself in a
situation that you haven't been before
it's gonna be beneficial to you now what
is it how does this translate to real
physical confrontations right how do you
train for that well how often are you
putting on gloves in jujitsu how often
are you having somebody punch you in the
face how often are you having somebody
come up and push you around
they how offer you having people do
things that people can do in a street
fight right the people are gonna do in a
street fight that they wouldn't normally
do in a Jitsu match right for instance
in a street fight does anyone ever start
on the knees right they don't start on
the nose they don't so you don't start
on the knees in a street fight you don't
say hey you want to fight me and then
you then you get down on your knees and
so does the other guy now we figure out
what happens no street fights don't
start on the knees so you're almost and
people ask me this is actually somebody
asked me the other day what what should
I do when starting from the knees what's
a good take down I'm like pull guard
because why are you on your knees yeah
the best thing to do if your opponent's
on their knees stand up and kick them in
the face right yeah you're not gonna be
if your why would you be on your knees
so don't practice that so how do you
prepare for the the best way to prepare
for these combat situations is is is Jiu
Jitsu tournament a good way yes it is a
good way is boxing is is boxing a good
way is it good to do is smokers so you
figure out what it's like when somebody
some you want to talk about with someone
going wild will you get some of that's
untrained in boxing come thrown throwing
you know windmill haymakers at you 38 in
a row now they're gonna be exhausted
after that first 32 seconds but but you
will would have had to have withstand
and not get punched in the head no
because if you get punched in the head
by a wild haymaker I don't care who you
are if they connect with your chin
there's a possibility you might go down
so you need to be careful
so so don't just think oh just jiu-jitsu
hey go out train some boxing train some
more Thai and go and spar and if you can
do is smokers because its smokers pretty
easy to do in other words you don't need
to you don't need to do like a full
preparation camp and all that you know
you know it's an unofficial event so you
go do a smoker's and you're gonna
experience somebody going wild on you
yeah throwing haymakers at you throwing
crazy kicks at you do that do all these
things to get ready for those physical
confrontations and then then you also on
top of that you read and you look at
YouTube videos go watch youtube videos
before go watch YouTube videos of street
fights because you get to see what
people what kind of things people do
which which can be very effective right
you need to watch to learn to watch out
for sucker punches you need to learn to
watch out watch your back and watch you
sneaking up on you and be aware of your
surroundings and put your back against
the wall you know there's all these
little things that you can do to make
sure that you're not going to get
sucker-punched but you got to pay
attention to those things you know yeah
that what that wildness that he talks
about yeah like you know that is a huge
thing it's like a whole nother factor
where especially and exactly how he said
he's real he's real familiar with his
training partner right you know so man
you know the amount of cruising and kind
of relax and even during the role
there's probably significant amount of
it almost to the point where it seems
like anyway where he kind of maybe
expects that or you know even
subconsciously kind of he understands
that that's kind of part of the deal you
go against a complete stranger yeah and
he gets wild but it's like whoa this is
like it's kind of overwhelming you know
yeah and also even at the three stripe
white belt level the this other guy he
may he's got his little game he's got
his game that he plays and there's a
chance that as a three-strike white belt
you haven't learned that part of the
game so it just feels yeah crazy
yeah and that whole you know when you
compete for the first second time you
know just a earlier you see that as the
thing is the more you train the less
holes there are yeah right
holls you are there are in your game and
so if you're a three-strike wipeout you
might not have good guard replacement
Yeah right like you really haven't
learned how to replace the guard from
cross-eyed well if this guy happens to
be a guy that holds really well across
side and that's where he works his game
from man you're in big trouble
yeah you're in big trouble yes and it
all seems so unpredictable too at those
earlier stages cuz you don't know where
your holes are I mean you might know
some but you don't know yeah no you
haven't seen enough of the game and you
haven't been in enough situations where
you you can kind of stay calm and you
know all this stuff so to your point
where you say you got to be familiar
with the unfamiliar kind of thing
remember when Majeed started just
baseball bat choking everyone yeah yeah
these little weird setups and he would
let people pass his guard but he they'd
be thinking home about to score some
points on and boom they're getting
tapped out
yeah Braille it was so foreign that okay
so he went the to real real famous ones
at the time when he exploded on the
scene with these was it was Clarke and
Zach Mac so there's two matches and one
of them Zac Maxwell and mounted in army
bar now has it in the arm bar meanwhile
baseball chat but yeah choke is in not
but who cares because really that rule
could not rule but that situation of
kind of applies if you have someone in
the arm bar I don't care what I'm about
to break your arm
he's going for arm but he can't lean
back because a baseball bat chokes in
and he's like he's got a tap yeah I got
a strand of tat and then I think he was
Clark where he could have been the other
way around but either way Clark as of
now his exact words interlock I was here
at these matches world I know I was I
was I saw the videos but um yeah the
kind where Clark was like I know this
joke I'm in mouth or I'm in this good
position I know that this choke doesn't
work it simply doesn't work because I
have the advent and he gets choked
unconscious because he doesn't have sure
it might hurt in that is the case for a
lot of a lot of jokes where it's like
sure this her no no no don't even gotta
to know a good one doesn't even hurt yes
no just in yeah so what we're talking
about there is a guy named measured wits
machines last page yeah
right and he he came on to the scene
will say with uh well this is what's
interesting about this is the baseball
bat choke is not a new choke yeah it's
not a domain that people were unfamiliar
with it's just that he was doing it
really really well with really good
setups that people that's what that's
the part that people weren't expecting
it was a really good setups they were
really good set up so people weren't
expecting yeah and so he let people past
their guard or his guard but he had the
choke in they get across side and get
mounted or whatever go forearm locks and
they're tapping yeah because they
weren't expecting it yeah and even it
knows you know I mean Zach Maxwell and
and Clark Gracie just phenomenal
competitors black belt did you - I mean
been trained in their whole lives yeah
both of them got caught by that yeah gee
yeah yeah the the legitimacy of like the
way that whole thing went down was just
so astounding like just like how you
said like Clark yeah Clark has been
winning stuff from day one yeah and yeah
it's just crazy but it just shows you
know where you can you can be that good
you get just that one teeny tiny window
of unfamiliarity yeah that's creeps in
there and he's familiar but he'll just
have his way and then what was
interesting is as people started knowing
that that's what he's gonna go for but
he'd still get it yeah and actually he
and I trained with him before before you
know a few times or whatever and he
didn't do that to me and I was like hey
you know like what I didn't ask him why
didn't you do it to me but I was like do
people you know like does everyone ask
you to teach them or whether he's like
you know what people don't I don't even
really talk about anymore because I've
become so well known for that move that
it becomes it became less a part of my
life yeah it's like well it could happen
to where okay now once you go okay it
goes through a phase of hey I wasn't
expecting that and it worked because I
wasn't expecting it then it goes like
hey I was expecting it but it still
worked
yeah but then it gets to a point where
people just gonna I'm not gonna do you
like oh if he grabs my collar I need to
go in a totally different direction I
need to not do anything need to back out
what
and then it becomes where like you said
now its loses some of its effectiveness
because everyone is expecting that to be
the move that you do that's what having
a deep 100% like where there'd be like I
don't care what position I'm in I don't
care what position I have to give up
just do not get into that leg lock
position there you say and you can tell
with some of these matches I was like
yes I get it you know I get it but yeah
man that is how it goes but the chaos
thing
I think he should compete more yes yes
should compete more for sure but what
I'm saying is compete in jiu-jitsu for
sure but do some smokers do some muy
Thai do some wrestling matches do some
samba turn you know get out there yeah
there's some different competitions and
then on top of all that man do some
scenario-based training you know do some
self-defense based training at the
academy where somebody pulls out the the
the knife the famed knife whatever would
they call the fake knife and like let's
make sure we know how to deal with that
let's make sure we know how to deal with
a baseball bat like what are you gonna
do yeah what are you gonna do cuz
baseball bat you know what you do with
the baseball bat close the distance yeah
you know hey that's that's that's not
even really a game-changer as long as
you know what you're doing nice because
the distance with a knife and I are you
getting stabbed this problem yeah so you
got to make distance yeah in it again
man that just that familiarity like once
you go through it that's like almost
night and day in and of itself once
you've seen it if you've never seen it
as if you've seen it once like for that
first step is night and day so that's
good that he went through this really
yeah yeah and what's good the other good
psychologically you know he recognized
psychologically he recognized that he
lost his mind what he said he said I did
fear yeah I got fear Oh was it in one
match I completely lost focus and
control of my mind so once you that's
just in what you just said when you get
that when you experience that that's a
good thing to experience cuz then you
learn to recognize that you're losing
control and you're losing your mind and
you're gonna when you when you realize
that it allows you to start monitoring
it yeah I've never been because there's
people let her listen to this right now
that have
lost their mind before they've never
been overwhelmed by something I just not
known what to do never been frozen
you ever been frozen with fear frozen
with fear if you've never felt your
fight-or-flight thing engaged then when
it happens you won't know what it is
yeah you want to know what it is so that
way when it happens you can go okay know
what's happening right here yeah I'm
gonna make this I'm gonna make this
decision
yeah and how you're saying when you
train boxing or boxing yeah yeah and MMA
so when you get hit in the face and we
talked about this before when you get
hit in the face then you haven't really
been hit in the face before like that's
a it'll throw you off oh yeah to put
really mildly it'll throw you off so
especially yeah you're right because
when you see someone get punched in the
face in a movie and it seems like it
doesn't really faze them that much and
they keep going if that's what you
expect is gonna happen when you get
punched in the face that's the wrong
idea yeah because what's gonna rip if
you've never been punched in the face
before when you get punched it's a
little shocker yeah and there's pain and
your eyes get blurry and your you get a
little flash I mean there's a lot of
things that go on when you get punched
in the face once you get used to it
you're like yeah you can move right
through it exactly yeah but if you're
not used to it it's a problem yeah fully
and it's that's another one it's night
and day when a Gaiden has been hit in
the face a bunch times and is used to it
and a guy who's not used to it because
you know how like you can hit a guy in a
face or get hidden in the face and
they'll be like I'm done like I didn't
really expect this encounter this
experience you don't want again and then
other guys they'll get hit in the face
break their nose break their jaw this
stuff and then keep fighting you know
it's like dang so that night in a
situation if you're not used to it which
is essentially the same thing you went
through this guy went wild he wasn't
ready for this overwhelming experience
and he lost his mind so if you get hit
in the face like I remember great
punching me in my face so hard where I
don't know if he was mad or or just a
guy hires it all he punch me right
between the eyes
thought he broke my face and it was the
kind where it was the timing thing to
where I came in I was sure
right before a level changed or whatever
he it just connected
that's like boom and I remember thinking
because I just kept going and I remember
thinking dang I'm glad I was kind of
used to getting hit in the face cuz that
was kind of the very least paused me for
a long time like dang he would but I
mean when you imagine just that kind of
chaos and sensation that'll just stop
you but once you're used to it you're
good and this is a good point to bring
up with just with any kind of training
like leadership training right when you
have leaders that haven't been put in
certain situations before that's why
we're a national front we do like
role-playing exercises people and you
put people in situations the first time
you put them in situations like dealing
with a hostile subordinate that doesn't
want to do the plan the first time they
get put in that scenario they they just
Lou they just fall apart
no I told you to do it any okay let's
replay that by the third time you're
doing it already handling the job
handling the scenario infinitely better
infinitely better than they did the
first time so it's the same with
everything in life like the exposure to
it and the rehearsal of it gives you
such a massive advantage that to not
rehearse and to not train is it's
actually sad and that's actually the the
Ashlyn fronts a great example because
that's why we're in business because
people people don't even know that they
should be doing this yeah and and to go
to a company that has fifty a hundred a
hundred and fifty two hundred leaders
that are leading teams and they have no
leadership training and therefore we're
all surprised when the leader doesn't
get the teams to do what they're
supposed to do well who taught him how
to lead you just don't show you just not
you just don't show up to work knowing
how to lead no you actually get trained
to lead yeah all these unfamiliar micro
scenarios half today and yeah you know
that's that's one of the that's quantico
like at the muster we do these little
drills at the muster and you could see
people are overwhelmed with the
knowledge that they gain from two or
three little scenarios that we put in
front of them and these are common
snares that happen all the time but when
you watch seasoned business leaders try
and handle a scenario that they haven't
seen before now they might have seen it
before but they never actually
to deal with it the first time they try
and deal with it they fall apart
yeah and it's real I would say it takes
like 10 seconds before you go okay let's
just stop because you've already got
this guy mad at you well let's try this
again cuz we we haven't been through the
situation before they never been punched
in the face before yeah and that's the
problem
yeah don't let it happen get punched in
the face a few times and yeah just you
be yeah you can do it it's kind of like
I remember when our kids there's this
there's this gum you know like Wrigley's
chewing gum yeah little packs at four or
five of them it's a small little thing
yeah and you know you grab one and this
one kind of sticky now you can say hey
you know do you want one you offer one
your friends so it was my brother and he
did a long story but he was crying from
something else who's that and he was
like crying in oh by the way you know he
offers me some gum I grab the gum it's
one of those mousetrap yeah yeah yeah
and it slaps you then kind of hurts we
need a little kitty anyway and it snaps
okay I'm like dang I never you know as
he's laughing he was crying from
something else and then he's laughing
cheered him up whatever double leg
[Laughter]
actually would have made the double leg
even better nonetheless I'd never seen
that before now someone offers me
Wrigley's gum I'm aware I'm ready for
that mousetrap maybe the mousetrap maybe
not but you're grabbing by the soccer
grandma side exactly right lesson
learned
yeah exactly right now after you into
her that I won't move my mind life is no
different
next question I'm a chef in a large
operation kitchen I'm second in command
overseeing a large kitchen staff and
part of a five-person management team
overseeing the entire account recently
during my last review I was given some
advice by my boss and his boss I'm
unsure about my last two annual reviews
have gone very well and I'm on the rise
in the company however they said if it
was important for me to get or heat the
Harvard they said it was important for
me to give up some of my kitchen dog
mentality and work to showcase my
artistic side and embrace more of a star
role in the spotlight
get out of the kitchen of
more gain more exposure specifically
with our high-profile clients while I
appreciate their sentiment and respect
their big management skills their style
isn't one I strive to emulate or feel
would work from me and the way I operate
I have always approached my work is more
of a craft than an art and I've always
liked being a trench dug with my team my
team responds to it and I get results
for the business and I feel the results
should speak for themselves
it has propelled my career rapidly thus
far so why would I want to change and be
something I'm not
should I heed their advice or stick to
what I do best
and keep getting after it on my terms
it's just funny how how that last
statement is framed right should I stick
to what I do best and keep getting after
it as if to say if you say no you should
not stick to what you do best it's like
you should not get after it right that's
that's the frame there and actually this
guy answered the question real tersely I
think this came through Facebook
messages you know I said sounds like you
found a comfortable zone for yourself
and you want to stay in there right cold
blooded response and he's like I knew it
because as we know in the comfort zone
there's there's no growth in the
confidence so it's interesting this guy
is actually getting some some good solid
and straightforward advice from up the
chain of command plus I think if they
have him as more of a personality than
the restaurant will do better and
they're trying to build their reputation
and your reputation at the same time and
that seems pretty reasonable to me
right and I'm not real familiar with the
restaurant business but I'm familiar
enough to know if you've got a good
reputation with the staff that works at
the restaurant it brings in more people
like there's no doubt about it
the relationship just like any other
business the relationships that you
build with the customers strengthens
them strengthens that relationship and
makes them want to come back for more
right that's the way it works and so for
them to say to you hey man hey you know
you're
good cook we get that but we need a
little bit more we want a little bit
more chef we need somebody that has yeah
chef can't see you're good you're good
yeah yeah sorry you're a good chef well
actually what I I think I might have
actually purposely said that like hey
you're doing a good job in the kitchen
as a cook we don't need someone that's
just cooking the food we need a chef
with a reputation with a personality
right yeah there's a difference there
right yes sir so it was called out for a
reason gotcha
he's happy and you can see like kitchen
dog yeah it's proud of that right and I
get that man I get that I get that like
you're one of the boys you're back in
the in the grind well let me let me ask
you this or let me make this statement
guess what you have to do as a seal as a
co-leader guess what you have to do you
have to build relationships you have to
make your commanding officer trust you
you have to build relationships with the
arm you have to build relationships
through the Marine Corps you have to in
order to do that you have to like raise
your you have to call a little bit of
attention to yourself and raise your
hand and say hey this is who I am you
have to take this is Who I am you you
have to actually have to step into the
spotlight a little bit so that you can
let people know who you are because if
people don't know who you are how do you
have relationship with it and if you
don't have relationship with people how
can they trust you so so that's part of
it right that's part of what they're
asking you to do now in all seriousness
if if you really don't want to do it
well then you can keep being the guy
that's in the back and guess what you're
gonna be mad in six months when some
other chef gets hired for a different
shift and all of a sudden he's out
making friends with everyone he gets
promoted and why does he get promoted
well look what the guys doing but he's
not as good as he's not as good as a
cook as I am guess what they don't
really care being making the food is
only part of what they want you to do
just like being a seal doing the doing
missions is only part of what they what
you need to do to do the mission yeah
you can't just be tactically sound
you've got to have the relationship
though so you can work in the battle
base that's owned by a conventional
commander you got to have the
relationship that you can get your
missions approved up the chain of
command on a special operation side how
do you do that you build you go out you
talk to people you get out of your
comfort zone it's a weird thing you know
I'm kind I'm kind of anti-social
right like if you don't know me we're
not gonna have a conversation you know
like we're not having a kind of like
it's not I'm not I'm not walking up and
talking to you if I don't know you I'm
not walking up and saying hi to you it's
not happening it's not my personality if
you say hi to me I'll say hi I'm not
disrespectful I'm not rude but I'm not
looking to have a bunch of conversations
with people and so that's known to me
but that's not okay
for the business side of my life which
is hey I gotta talk to people gotta
build relationships gotta had to know my
commanding officer had to know the
Commodore had to know the the the
conventional battalion commander had to
know the brigade commander had to build
relationships could I just talk about
war with the brigade commander well I
could but what's more powerful that I
talk about war and I talk about where
I'm from or where he's from or what you
know other things yes because I want to
build a relationship but why because I'm
trying to build trust what why because I
wanted to allow me to go out there and
do things in his battle space so that's
what they're asking here they're asking
you to step out of your comfort zone
it doesn't need to become your primary
focus no should you try and step out of
the comfort zone if you want to grow if
you want to have more opportunity I
would give it a try I would give it a
try if not you know like I said if you
hate it and you feel like you're not
being true to your true self that's okay
maybe your true self is meant to be the
one that's back not getting promoted
yeah they need somebody to do that yeah
it's not you it might be somebody else
yeah there's another one of those tough
questions where people you know hit me
with like should I just be
should be loyal to myself because the
the obvious that can't answer that
everyone wants to hear is like yeah dude
the most important thing he's gotta be
loyal to yourself that's the most
important thing okay if that's what your
priority is then that's the most
important thing but guess what who does
a who can take care of the other kitchen
dogs that respect you so much who can
take a better care of them than you can
because if you get promoted if you don't
get promoted and and Johnny glamour boy
gets promoted because he likes to go out
and schmooze the clients and now he gets
promoted and yours and now who's gonna
take care of the kitchen dogs on his on
his time right not him he doesn't care
he's got he got promoted not for taking
care of his guys he got promoted cuz he
schmooze the clients and play the game a
little bit it's weird man you're
explaining that and it's like makes
complete sense I'm thinking of it in
terms of like beena
I don't know I guess it applies to any
relationship you have some so like let's
say okay you have a wife right you're
buried whatever and so your wife wants
to go to hypothetically wife wants to go
to I don't know Vermont you know like
hey I don't like Vermont you know go to
Vermont whatever but your wife say hey I
want you to come because I like spending
time with you and in all this stuff and
as a husband you like hey I like
spending time with you too why can't we
do something that I specifically like to
do or whatever and it has to do so a lot
of times with like maybe your wife's
friends or they enlarge so I don't want
to hang with I won't hang with you but I
want to hang with them and I want to
hang with you with the friends and all
this stuff or whatever but a lot of the
time in my case might have been me just
sticking in my little comfort zone you
know like the people that I like to hang
out with it there there's like set stuff
that I know they're into and I know they
like to talk about it and all this stuff
and I'm essentially rejecting being open
to new or other stuff you know that's
yeah that's kind of like a situation but
in a way I'm kind of doing what this
what this guy is implying where it's
like I'm gonna stay true to myself and
interests and all this stuff I love my
wife 100% that has nothing doing that
Vermont has nothing to do with me and my
wife you know but why shouldn't I step
outside of my comfort zone and you know
try to accommodate her wishes in this
way it's not a make or break a
relationship or nothing like that but if
I do that if I just exercise the ability
to be open I become more valuable of a
husband more valuable
I offer more value in the relationship
and as a person so same exact thing when
you're explaining this when this guy's
explaining where he's awesome
as a chef in the back doing the you know
doing this deal doing what he does best
awesome but they and these guys see it
mr. berry see it obviously where they're
like hey we want you to do this more
stuff even cuz you're awesome and men
imagine if you had this more stuff you
know valuable you would be as a XYZ
whatever the position is in this case is
a chef and to reject that is essentially
to say you know what I I don't want to
be more valuable as a chef or I don't
want to be more valuable as a husband I
prefer to stick with my current value
I don't want up green there you go I
refuse to upgrade so I'm staying true to
myself just saying anyway I mean can you
cross the line and get to a point where
you make yourself sick because you've
done yeah then you've gone too far
that's knit I caught me a leadership
like yeah if you become just a
disgusting sycophant and yeah that's
what that's not good yes I'm not talking
about that yeah I'm not talking about
leaving your values and abandoning your
values that's not what I'm talking about
right talking about playing the game a
little bit there's a big difference
step outside a comfort zone play the
game a little bit at the very least do
it with an open mind see how you like it
what if you were like you got real good
at that you know I like public speaking
for example where I'm no exception
a lot of people didn't like public
speaking even though they might have a
lot to say or whatever you know like
some people like they're smart but I
don't want to get up on stage nothing
like that that's dumb I'm not a star I
don't want the limelight on me and all
this stuff they do want
and they in they offer like just so much
value doing it and then they get used to
it then all of a sudden they kind of
like it you know it could be one of
those deals could be could be you never
know till you try it
next question two of my bosses have told
me I don't like Jocko interesting
without giving any value valid reasons
their ego is in the way how do I flank
them to help them see the path my belief
is that they're afraid of the truth and
they say they're afraid of the truth
they see in extreme ownership okay so
yeah I mean clearly ego could be a
problem here as a leader you know who
wants to constantly be compared to some
other leader right you know if you were
teaching a jujitsu well the way that the
way that Dean teaches this you know that
would make you mad afterwards so that
could be part of the problem that's
death that's definitely yeah that's way
up there on the list of possible things
could be the military flavor right some
people don't like the military flavor of
things so that's that's okay it's it's
can turn some people off that I want to
hear about it that's fine
the reality is here's the a but here's
the reality of the situation okay
what is there to not like about the
things that I talk about right so let's
say you know what I don't like people
taking ownership I want everyone to make
excuses and blame each other right it
doesn't even make sense you know instead
of you know we I don't want to hear
about this cover move I want everyone to
ignore each other and get worried about
themselves right like that makes no
sense whatsoever
you know if key keeping things simple I
don't want to hey look I don't want to
keep things simple I want everything to
be so complicated that no one knows
what's going on right like these things
they make no there's no human being no
one in a leadership position that would
want everyone or that would that would
go against what these simple principles
so how do you fix it then right what's
the problem
one here's a couple and actually this
was a Twitter thing and a bunch of
people gave great responses on Twitter
after I kind of highlighted it one one
of them and my actual responses like hey
just don't you know stop using my name
you know stop saying well chocolates it
cuz you can imagine how annoying that
was what jock was in you know when
you're in a leadership position it's
like that's gonna really great on
somebody so so so throw that out the
window don't hit it as me Jaakko against
what your bosses are saying no don't do
that you've set up an adversarial
relationship with them and you've set up
for an ever adversary relationship with
me and I've ever you met these people
before I don't know who they are even
know what business they're in but what
you've done by constantly harping on it
is you've pissed them off and now
they're saying dude quit talking about
jakka we don't care cuz also the way
that he's interest the way he's being
offensive in approaching these things
means that he has a little more
listening and growing to do because if
you really want to approach your boss or
you know he asked about flanking as
possible the way you flank someone isn't
going hey the way jocular says you
should do this like no that's not good
so let the principles work on another
another person pointed out you know
hey don't hey stop trying to impose your
things on them like take extreme
ownership how's that sound
you step up and start leading you do
your thing you perform well quit talking
quit trying to force these things down
people's throats and give them space
give them room and then they'll
recognize that you're doing a good job
if you label it with something that you
know they don't like well then they're
gonna not gonna like it no matter what
you do no matter what you do that's
gonna be problematic
don't bludgeon them with with will you
know I
this is blah blah blah no don't do that
hmm take let put your ego in check how's
that sound for your you go and check a
little bit make the ideas that you're
talking about their ideas get them to
talk about ownership you know get them
maybe they call it something else other
than extreme ownership maybe they call
it you know personal accountability okay
awesome
that's great yeah I really like
that I really like what you've come up
with boss I'm in with oh well now
they're in the game and they don't
realize that you're talking about the
same thing that's fine don't they don't
ever have to realize that they don't
ever have to realize that so maybe
there's some people but some people that
don't live even in the teams there's
people that like they didn't like me
didn't matter didn't matter where what
the the principle was didn't make no
that's no it's like a no like hey just
just just don't don't attach my name to
it yeah and go and do be a good leader
how's that so those are some things I
think if you live live the principles
act on the principles no one's gonna be
mad at you for taking ownership and
responsibility of what you're doing
unless you say oh you like how I took
ownership of that well then you might
paint yourself into a corner with yeah
stupid or they end up not accepting what
you're doing yeah and they'll get mad at
you for stepping on their toes I of
course and it is also as you do this as
you take ownership don't rub their noses
in it
mmm you give them credit how hard is
that you know you come up with a front
solution to problem say hey you know
actually I got this idea from someone
saw you do it
really right that's how you that's how
you flank them and took ownership of
this problem oh really oh here we go
extreme don't say that don't say that
you know it's like a boss I I wanted to
make sure this got done correctly I was
watching the way you did bah bah bah bah
you go from there give them the idea you
make sense it yeah I do I wonder how the
boss got introduced to the concept of
Jocko for him to eventually hey not like
in this situation it probably was like
you know multiple repetitions of what
yeah yeah and didn't pick up the vibe
yeah which is like hey you I'm dealing
with someone with a big ego and they're
not gonna take well to me talking about
this other guy's leadership style do you
you don't wanna be compared to some
other leader if you're in the leadership
position yeah and I know man also it's
kind of the same thing but a little bit
different the that thinking about that
type of scenario man that's the worst
that's like
as a boss I would think that that'd be
really bad because okay so here here's a
his situation so I make videos sometimes
right and so let's say I'm and actually
this is an actual thing that actually
happened where okay so I made this video
for this will say client and classic
okay you know they look at it and it's
typical you know they'll have some input
maybe some information they want to add
or take or change or whatever and then
um this guy said oh yeah I'm not sure
about this part I showed it to my wife
and she said you know X Y Z and X I'm
thinking okay I get it like okay he
showed it to people that I understand
but I was like wait wait so this is a
video made for you in your deal you know
kind of thing and you went and showed
your wife and then now she has some kind
of input she's not part of this deal you
know now you're like citing your wife's
critique and like all this stuff and it
doesn't make sense by the way as far as
what we've discussed it on the stuff
right so look so the wife is good now I
kind of have this kind of disdain for
the wife I don't know why if at all by
the way so I'm like I'm just not feeling
the wife you know where ego got in the
way and it's natural is what I'm saying
where it's kind of like I thought we
were doing this video kind of together
and I'll do this for you and you give me
the input right now you involved your
wife in it who through the whole thing
off because she's not even part of this
little thing right now
really hard to put your ego in check
it's really hard to put your ego in
check and actually listen to what the
critique points are it's easy it's hard
for anyone to do that you know and so
when it happens you have to go okay
that's my ego and you need to put it
aside yeah
so consider this situation if the guy
would have just said don't say I showed
it to my wife and she said this don't
say if he would have said well I was
thinking about this which is what the
wife said they don't know in there
whatever now figure out this whether it
would add it got delivered way better
way easier the same thing with your your
situation if someone's saying I don't
know let's say for example it's a
fireman it's a fireman and you know the
boss is saying hey we should do this and
do that and then this guy just horribly
says that will Jocko said boss is like
who the hell is John I don't remember
hiring Jocko who's this guy and what's
he talking about cool
but Jocko has no say in this department
it's me it's you it's the team you know
the team that we've worked with kind of
thing and that's kind of the feeling so
yeah man don't say jock yeah I don't
need to credit not all next question
chuckle please explain how working
harder for an incompetent superior helps
oneself
I feel like screw them and whatever
lightning bolt of luck they were struck
by it again in their position that kinda
like screw them and the horse they rode
in on yeah that is no he's saying screw
them and they they were there they're in
their position of superior because they
got lucky yeah yeah I didn't get all
that screw them yeah and you know here's
the answer that is like okay so what he
can do that okay what are you gonna do
then you're gonna sit around and wait
for your own bolt of lightning of luck
to hit you is that what you're gonna do
I don't recommend that instead I I
recommend that you step up and yes you
do work harder and you do the best
possible job that you can do and you
take some pride in what you're doing and
how you're doing it and you do it better
than they could not to rub their nose
into it not to prove that you can do it
better but out of professionalism that's
why you do it now one outcome that can
come from that is they get credit for
your work and that makes y'all mad no
that's actually good because if they get
credit for your work that's what works
going well they're gonna get promoted
and they get the recognition okay that's
fine
but but they know where the actual
credit goes even if they don't give it
to you even if they don't give it to you
they know it even if they're the type of
person that doesn't even realize that
you're like oh I did all that work and
he's taking all the credit for they
don't even know that I made this happen
or he doesn't even know that he that I
made this happen they know they know so
as long as you can keep your a ego in
check and you can let them have the
credit eventually they get promoted the
team's doing well
you'll look good you'll get promoted
your life is easy
you're gaining experience you've got a
good reputation like everything is going
in your direction and and by the way
when that incompetent person does get
promoted who do they usually recommend
that fills their spot you because you're
the one that got them promoted that are
stoked on that now you become a
superstar that's great eventually
they're gonna get found out by the way
like someone the incompetency can't be
hidden forever and eventually someone
says wait a second you don't even know
how to do this that was that was echo
Charles that was doing this this whole
time yeah okay okay well we're gonna
promote echo you're out of here that
that'll happen and when that happens
when that incompetency gets found out
then you will get the recognition you
deserve cuz people said how that wasn't
Jocko doing all this stuff this was that
go mm-hm Oh Jacques ooh you're done so
that's so that's something to happen or
another outcome that can happen is that
they give you the credit that that
you're due which is great and you still
get promoted and you may get promoted
above them which is fine too or and or
they might get promoted which is fine
stop worrying about it so those two
things if you do a good job eventually
something good is gonna come out of it
whether it's they get whether it's you
both get promoted whether it's they get
promoted above you whether it's you get
promoted above that it doesn't matter
all those outcomes or maybe it's just
the team continues to do well and your
job is stress-free and you continue to
perform and and the the the division
that you're in grows and you get a
chance to promote because everyone's get
it's like all good all good stuff mmm or
you can be angry and you can be
frustrated and you can blame your own
bad luck and you cannot work hard and
you can not do a good job and you can be
recognized as a slacker you can get
blamed by the incompetent boss when
things do fall short because that's what
the incompetent boss does he doesn't
step up and take ownership of it he says
no you know what I would have done a
better job but echo was slacking that's
the problem
now echo gets fired and and guess what
someone that we hire someone else to
come in and they start doing a good job
that boss still gonna look good and and
still good promote it's just that you
lost your job and by the way you lost
your job with a bad reputation now you
can't even get a recommendation for a
new job so you lose
that's what's gonna happen yeah so step
up do your best
it'll pay off in the long run yeah it's
funny how like it's one of those things
where if you can just flip the switch
and see that just think it's funny
though - the way that's good the way
these questions are framed you know what
they want to hear is like no you know
what if you got an incompetent boss you
don't help him out yet umber yeah that's
what you do that's what people want to
hear it's but it's it's the easy answer
and it's not the smart answer
and it's a short-term answer or not a
long-term answer you make your boss look
great
how's that that's my goal I wanna make
my boss look great you know there there
was little tell in the question - I'm no
expert obviously but lightning bolt of
love blah yeah so you know the whole
deal and this is even you can be a known
person to recognize this like people who
are bitter I'm not saying the asker of
this question is good I'm not saying
that I'm saying this is a external
scenario but you know if you get a
bitter person who's just better in life
maybe not doing as well in life as they
had you know had hoped or whatever
you'll probability-wise
you'll probably encounter them from time
to time some more saying how the guy who
is successful is lucky they're lucky
they had a given to them like all this
all this other stuff me I'm not lucky
whatever whatever but it's always the
second successful guy is lucky always
yeah they attribute other people's
success to Locke to luck for her so the
lightning bolt of luck and screw them
you know kind of thing just that is
indicative I'm not saying it is I'm not
saying it is or isn't as far as this
particular person but it tends to be
like that and again like that just that
switch if you can like turn on the
switch and just look at it just like how
you said it's not intuitive I get it man
because it's like they say I was in that
situation we're like literally I was
doing the work so me think about this
you just said you're in this situation
almost everybody has been in the
situation and here's the difference
if you don't flip that switch and you're
in this situation your whole life goes
down in the other direction yeah that is
real problem that's why you meet people
yeah you know this is a thing I think
about a lot of you you know how you
you know people in your life they're
badasses but they but they're not going
anywhere
like like you look under you go man this
guy's smarter than me and and a better
athlete than me and a better speaker
than me
but they're not going anywhere and you
know why it's because at some point in
their life instead of saying oh wow that
guy's that guy's lucky that's what they
do at some point their life instead of
saying hey that person worked to get in
that situation and I should do the same
instead of saying that they say that
person got lucky yeah that's why they're
there and I'm down here yeah yeah you
can't make the upward climb if you don't
say you know what hey that person might
be a little luck there but guess what
they're obviously working hard they're
obviously doing something right because
I'm down here and they're up there how
do I get up there yeah the answer to get
up there is not by tearing them down the
answer to get up there is by working art
yeah make them look good that line you
said what and so what are you gonna do
about it yeah what are you gonna do but
that's the switch right there cuz I mean
you deal with it with kids I've seen
some young kids and you know same thing
like oh oh it is or this happened or
whatever
spilt milk I don't know whatever and you
know the kids crying and so this stuff's
like okay so what are you gonna do about
it so you can cry he totally can and you
can complain about how junk that is that
the milk that spilled to your toy broke
or whatever the situation yeah cuz
that's all truth absolutely true and
good you can cry whatever but if that's
what you're gonna do about it then okay
then that's what its gonna be and that's
all it's gonna be gonna continue to cry
and you'll probably continue to cry next
time it happens too or you clean up the
milk you fix your toy whatever you know
whatever what are you gonna do about it
that's the learning you know what are
you gonna do but it's interesting too
there's like just a known the the right
answer seems really obvious when we talk
about it right now but not many people
see that right answer no most people
want to just be mad at their boss and be
frustrated and undermine them and not
work hard so that they don't get any
shine on them it's like okay great
that's you putting yourself in that
barrel - yeah don't do it
yeah I actually shouldn't say it's crazy
it's it makes sense I mean I felt that
before 100% yeah oh for sure sure dick
swish can you be default aggressive and
relaxed in jiu-jitsu okay yeah this
seems like two opposing things that you
can't do at the same time but the actual
fact is yes you can and you should
so you want your maneuvers to be
aggressive but you don't want to be
using a bunch of strength to execute the
maneuvers right you want to aggressively
escape your opponent's position before
your opponent gets settled therefore you
don't have to use strength you can use
relax it you can relax you can you can
be proactive same thing with defending a
submission attempt you want to defend
that submission attempt aggressively
before this submission attempt gets
settled in you want to move aggressively
again I'm not talking about strength and
spazzing I'm talking about moving
aggressively before your opponent moves
and get ahead of them on their loop when
you get ahead of them on their hooter
loop they're gonna have issues with you
and so yeah absolutely you can be
default aggressive and at the same time
you can be relaxed and you should that
should be your goal do you sometimes
have to use strength in jujitsu yes you
do yes you do sometimes you got a power
out of something
why did you the reason you had to power
out or something is cuz you were too
late because you weren't moving
aggressively enough you weren't moving
quickly enough and then you got a power
out of something gotta call all those
hands claw that guillotine off your neck
you know what I'm saying you want to get
Agee telling someone they're clawing
your fingers away from their neck yes
yeah so when that happens that person
was late and and now they're clawing
they're resorting to strength they're
resorting to panic clawing at your
fingers sometimes don't usually doesn't
even matter in claw it doesn't matter
good like that sense of panic that I
feel what they're clawing yeah I'm sure
you do you really so that's what that's
what it is and by the way this is true
and
as well right like if if you are
maneuvering correctly correctly as a
leader you don't have to get aggressive
at people because they're doing what
they're supposed to be doing yeah you
don't have to be
you shouldn't have to yell if you have
to yell as a boss guess what your your
intent wasn't followed your plan wasn't
understood there's so many mistakes that
you made if you're yelling as a leader
do you never have to yell yeah sometimes
you can yell because you got to make
sure you get that emotional point across
sometimes you got to make sure that
someone real like someone doesn't seem
to realize that the mistake that they
made is severe enough that that it
warrants yelling and therefore it
doesn't matter to them because their dad
yelled in their whole life well so if
you're not yelling they don't get it
so can you couldn't can you run to that
cake problem occasionally occasionally
very occasionally very very rarely
should you run into that situation
because if you're doing the right job
being default aggressive as a leader you
should be in situations where you never
have to yell because your people because
you people understand what it is that
they're supposed to be doing they
understand why they're supposed to be
doing it they understand what the plan
is they understand what the
contingencies were they understand what
the what the intent that you had was
they understand that's the way that this
fits strategically into the situation
they understand all those things and if
they understand all those things then
they're gonna do the right thing and if
they don't if they understand all those
things and they still do something that
that doesn't make sense
well me maybe they do deserve get yelled
at but again all the first person our
check is myself and say obviously I to
make this clear enough mm-hmm so yes
relax harder so yelling is to leading as
using strength is to jujitsu someone
gotta do it everyone yeah everyone so or
if you lay maybe you'll act on your
technique earlier you're gonna kind of
but think about this you hurt your
stamina yeah he's your strength right
yeah when I yell at you because
something went wrong and you're my
subordinate when I yell at you I paid a
little price for that too
yeah cuz they better be important and I
better really think about it cuz I
didn't do anything to build our
relationship in a positive manner by
yelling you right didn't do anything
yeah
just like you didn't improve your
jujitsu technique rhinology knees or or
really you I guess you improved your
situation for a moment right because you
were safe but now you're more tired just
like if I yelled at you to do something
and you did it because you real you know
you were like okay well fine I want you
yelled at anymore something's gonna do
this the thing that he told me to do
that
it's temporary fix it's a temporary fix
yeah you know how like JP will say um
aggressive it isn't or default
aggressive isn't towards people it's
towards making things happen so like so
in digits the same thing so it's like I
don't regress is like it's in it in a
way you kind of can narrow it down to
the timing thing it's like it's like
it's either taking action or hesitating
kind of thing so you just don't really
hesitate you can lay back if that's part
of the strategy and stuff like that you
can relax when it's part of the strategy
but it's about making things happen like
what are you try to make things happen
timing wise so you know how like you
have think Tim Ferriss asks what is the
disrespect remember you asked me that
what's the disrespect oh you're do that
you made up but yeah you made up the
terminology as well so the disrespect is
as basically at when a guy pulls guard
or you're in a guard scenario it's
actually not even a guard scenario yet
it's like you essentially treat that
person like they don't even have a
garden like the guard doesn't even exist
that's how little respect you have for
the garden then you just pass but when
you kind of think about it when I think
about it when you've done it to me three
times you have it is literally that so
before I can establish any kind of
position to establish guard you're just
boom just yeah you're past it you're
done you know you don't even consider
the guard you know what's weird is is
where people get confused on this though
is they think oh so you're saying move
faster yeah right that's the weird thing
yeah it is it's not it's I'm sure I'll
think of this at a later time but it's
not about moving faster it's about
moving more aggressively yeah it's not
faster it's like being proactive and
being aggressive and and shutting down
the situation before
before it even becomes the situation
that you know it's going to become you
know so if you take you said like like
if you take taking action and hesitation
you take those two it's basically you're
narrowing the hesita
down to zero it's possible literally
what it is yeah just take action and
again you can relax
you can wait but it's not hesitation
waiting it's waiting that's like more
like being patient or waiting for a very
specific reason you can do like all
those things but there's no hesitation
that's what I think that is and then
obviously it's gonna vary yeah this is
something you hear over and over and
over again in combat leadership
philosophies like doing something now is
better than waiting yeah I mean doing
something doing something that's pretty
good right now is on infinitely better
than doing something that's great in two
days yeah the aggressive make something
happen
yeah like that is so important can you
overdo it yes you can can you make
stupid decisions because you rushed yes
you can
is there a dichotomy in this absolutely
there is the that's there's a dichotomy
in every part of it so in every type of
leadership there's a dichotomy in
jujitsu right there's a doctor because
if I just rush to a situation well that
might be the situation that you want to
be - right you gave me the opening the
trap yeah so it's like you know when
you're like helping your friend move and
then you get like three four other
friends you know and everyone's waiting
around to be like okay where do we start
okay where do we put you know where do
we start who's starting first kind of
thing
the default aggressive guy he's just
gonna start moving stuff yeah and that
seemed like okay that's like a little
light-hearted scenario but but that's
real that's what I would run into it you
know one that there's a bunch of people
and we're all capable of making the
decision it kind of paralyzes everyone
because oh this is so true it that
scenario that you're talking about it
happens over and over and over again in
the business world it happens over and
over again on the battlefield it happens
on the training field where there's a
bunch of people no one's taking
leadership position yeah like all it
takes is someone to say hey we're moving
this over here to get all the stuff off
the truck right now boom guys are like
okay cool we'll make it happen
yeah like your oil rig scenario the main
exact same thing yeah and if your
default aggressive meaning that's your
default that's the that's your zero
you'd hear that 100% then you're just
paneling business right your whole life
until you take it too
far yeah and you're trying to run stuff
that other people might have a better
vision of what to do like if I might be
I found my only movement for the first
time ever mmm on our movin team and I
come in I'm like hey guess what hey
we're gonna start getting this to heavy
stuff and you're like hey actually
that's not a good idea yeah we should do
this we should get this stuff in here
into the truck first or whatever right
because you've been doing it longer so
even though it's got to be your default
mode again there's a dichotomy you can
push it too far
keep your eyes open that question to do
one more Jaakko how do self awareness
self assessment and self-improvement
begin and how do they continue over time
well they're all tied together and it
starts with being self-aware with being
able to detach because if you if you
can't detach from yourself then you
can't see yourself and so people ask
well then how do you detach from
yourself how do you learn to do that and
a good drill for this is try to imagine
the way other people see you and what
other people are thinking of you and one
place where this happens and it
definitely happened to me is when I
started getting put in charge of things
I started thinking about other people's
perspectives what are they seeing if
you're in charge then what are your
subordinates see you do what are your
subordinates here you say what kind of
representation are they receiving in if
you work for someone else it's the same
questions what does the boss see me do
what does the boss hear me say what kind
of representation am i making of myself
to my boss and then you start thinking
about what are you
friends and family think what do they
see what do they hear and so the
question becomes how well do you
represent yourself what shortfalls do
you have now when you first start
looking it's like you're looking at an
overgrown lawn there are some big
obvious problems so you do a broad just
kind of general cut of the grass you fix
some of the big easy problems that are
obvious but once you've done that once
you've gotten rid of some of those big
obvious problems you notice some more
detailed problems say then you handle
them and once you've got those handled
you see even smaller and more detailed
issues so you start trying to fix them
and that's what you do with yourself you
continually detach and then you look and
then you refine and then you detach and
then you look and then you refine and
then you detach and you look and then
you refine that's what you do that's how
you get better and that process doesn't
stop it can't stop because if you stop
refining then then the weeds grow back
and the next thing you know you can't
see yourself anymore then when you can't
see yourself anymore when you stop
looking at you yourself then you accept
you accept anything and that's wrong
don't accept the faults don't give
yourself the benefit of the doubt you've
got to be your own harshest critic and
hold the line
and don't let go
and I think that's all I've got for
tonight
so echo Charles yes
speaking of improving ourselves sir have
any recommendations as to how we might
be able to improve ourselves a little
bit sure improve and maintain improve
maintain improve me well something like
that I would recommend okay let's start
with the workup right work it out is
established and known well known by the
way to be one of the only things that
you can do that all affect every other
part of your life in a good way
it's also one of those things that well
more health if you lose that you lose
everything it's one of those things so
why do some of us not regard it in that
way 100% of the time why is why do
people not have time to exercise lack of
discipline yeah possibly
it might be that short-term payoff thing
you know it's natural to seek short-term
path it's natural I think that's it
because again you lose your health you
lose everything straight up so why
wouldn't health be first on the priority
list I don't have time to exercise no
you have to exercise you might not have
time to the rest of the stuff in life
really that's how it should be right
nonetheless when you're exercising you
joints might generate but don't worry
about that even chocolate supplements
jockle supplements jaco super krill oil
this is omega-3s for your joints for a
lot of other stuff too by the way brain
skin skin tone that's like a
supplemental thing but it is good for it
nonetheless that's a fact and another
one called choco joint warfare so your
joints when you start to lose the
functionality of your joints not only
does it make workouts less
desirable less phone effective less fun
less everything it can it can jam up
your health do it physically you can be
less capable so you want to maintain
your joints I didn't know this but now
that I do I'm never looking back
chuckles super krill take that and joint
warfare maintain the joints maintain
joint health every single day get the
subscription so you don't run out that's
what I say
straight up I think there's a panic mode
if you run out yeah and you don't want
that panic mode you need that panic well
you need that in your life even so why
even bother so get the subscription do
the recurring one every month everything
wants however often you take him
depending you know
oh how nuts you want to get also Jaco
has a supplement this is for your brain
and your body all in one you don't have
to take the pre-workout and the
cognitive enhancing nootropic you don't
have to do that anywhere you take two
just the ones called discipline tastes
good too lemon lime force multiplier is
what we call it yeah boom that's a good
one I think that that'll help you
they'll take help you'd stay on task
find all the words that you're looking
for to use you know you don't want what
would he call that anyway that brain
fart brain farts such a lame word not
only it's not lame word the lame word
when I said absent-mindedness
absent-mindedness you know it kind of
combats all that stuff present
mindedness is the opposite of apps
technically yeah nonetheless promote
that and you're all good it's called
discipline get all these at or Jemaine
calm the company is origin
I say origin main I just that's the
company I said its origin main but it's
really called origin it's in Maine and
the website is origin Maine dot-com also
an origin me geez and rash guards for
your jujitsu journey important journey
by the way I would say ninety I would
say every 100 percent of 100 percent
almost 90% of people who start jujitsu
will say okay it's valuable whether they
stick with it or not you cannot deny the
value of jujitsu
even with a is that one of the questions
earlier boom you inoculate yourself you
know to all these things and it's weird
how it affects the rest of your life
yeah for your whole life yeah
nonetheless when you start you can ask
what key should I get guess what origin
you get an origin key made in America
the fabrics made in America the cotton
to make the fabric is made in America
grown in America see we're going all the
way down to grown straight up from dirt
from the dirt to the sugar shirt to the
key top to all that stuff they also got
hoodies pizza and made some new sweat
suit situation
no joggers are they nice got him on
right now straight up most comfortable
comfortable clothes thing this goes for
all clothing I've ever had just and
that's saying a lot straight up is
straight up yes how do you say um is it
because it's made in America maybe maybe
not
but it does speak a lot for the quality
of origin in and of itself and oh wait
it's comfortable because it was made in
America
that's the question is it or isn't it I
don't know but it is comfortable 100
percent the most most comfortable I know
it is because you are one that deals
high in comfort I know my comfort levels
yes I'm a comfort connoisseur 100
percent and this one graded off the
charts check bet you'd lay down you take
a break so I export stuff you know in
video editing special effects co2
exports so 3d stuff export and takes a
long time 3d studio max that's what it's
called
Thanks long time so while it exports you
start using your computer doing other
things it kind of you know it can jam
you up it'll slow down your computer
whatever so you know I take a little
break I'm gonna lay down on the couch I
got my origin whole sweat suit on gets
up and I lay down on the cup like this
for some reason I'm the most comfortable
I've ever been in my you need to make we
I'll talk to Pete you need like a a
Signature Series you know you gotta do
is rename it embroidery on the side boom
I was cruising in comfort Oh big damn
day anything sure I say that and I know
comfort is kind of a subjective thing
maybe well okay I
anyone if you have the origin sweatsuit
or if you get one get on it lay down on
your couch temperature would have to be
just right because if it's hiding you
have sweat suit on not gonna be as
comfortable but keep that in mind I
challenge you to do that report back if
it's not the most comfortable let me
know for a 100 percent you get a taste
of real comfort american-made comfort
too by the way also if you're into
jiu-jitsu or if you're not introduced to
those in jiu-jitsu immersion camp on
August 26 this year goes to September
2nd one week through sessions in that
one week I'm going chuckles doing going
and so is Dave Burke the real Top Gun
the rays of God Burke yes good do you
know why he's going it sounded like a
good deal does not do non good deal
things yeah and good deal not in the
sense where it's like a good deal like
you know like I'm gonna get over it's
like a good deal like it's like it's
good it's a win-win-win-win-win
it's like the best-case-scenario kind of
thing that's what good deal Dave is all
about that's just a man it's how he is
how he rolls unless other people will be
there was it be there hopefully JP and
Lee yeah well Lafe just got his a strike
another stripe on the white belt on
white belt yeah so he's getting he might
very well be there I think I'll be a
blue belt by that maybe sure at this
pace yeah he keeps trying too hard yeah
and well he has prior knowledge as well
so yeah you never know yeah yeah so do
you see immerse yourself and you're just
the best way to learn in my opinion Marv
- no not even if you've never gotten go
cuz yeah last time with um I even went
on the side with beginner beginners like
one day zero days experience boom we go
through some stuff from and I'm not
saying look who I'm such a good teacher
I'm not saying that at all but after
like that session they were ready to go
start rolling humble brag I know this
because that's what they said not that
not all of them but cuz someone said
that unless I'm saying there's a lot of
value in jiu-jitsu value if you've never
done Judaism before ever Leah Jack
or gin mein kampf check it out see if
it's for you it's for you but you want
to make sure and check on that one it's
a good also ja close the store it's
called jaw closed or go to chocolate
store.com
so chuckle store is where you can get
shirts t-shirts
this would include for you get after it
shirt with chuckles big head on it this
is good just for those days that you
know you're powering through some
adversity whatever got chocolate oh
right on your shirt all good rash guards
hoodies patches beanies are either on
there or there like literally on the way
the wheels are in motion then check I
can't stop it can't stop it right now a
lot of cool stuff on there stickers some
details on there it's good anyway you
don't have to get something but go on
there check it out if you like something
get something really good way to support
also for workout gear equipment you want
to introduce some variety in movements
in your workout good place to go
kettlebells battle ropes maces go-to on
it calm slash jungle I once said well
actually more than once said that
chuckles workouts are boring they're not
I get it they're not boring Irie retract
that statement they're not boring but if
you run the risk of your workouts being
boring just get some new equipment
actually it's good because you know when
you get a new crate like it'd be even
like something that simple as a jump
rope right when you get it kind of
rejuvenates a little party you wanna you
know it's like when you get a new key go
to practice more you know you buy some
new running shoes like you're kind of
compelled to go running
so you're basically still a
five-year-old we kind of all are in a
way and if you go to on it comm get you
some new fitness gear it'll introduce a
little variety to your workout different
gear different movement different
workout keep you on the path even more
and make it interesting made fun man I
think that's my opinion
yeah on it dunk I'm / chuckle good spot
good way to
work also when you're buying any of the
books that we review on this podcast
don't worry I organized them on our
website talk about gas calm in the book
section just click through there get the
books through there and if you're doing
any other shop behave carry on do your
shopping good way to sort also subscribe
to the podcast if you have it already on
iTunes stitcher Google Play and any
podcast app that you might use a lot of
new apps by the way doing podcasts yeah
subscribe good with good way to support
also we have a youtube channel if you
are interested in the video version of
this podcast subscribe YouTube channel
there's some excerpts on there along
with the video version and enhanced
excerpts it's good deliver the message
with some I know some cool music or
something anyway shareable stuff like so
you don't have to share 2/3 our podcast
with someone and then you know when you
get something in your message or inbox
or whatever and it's two hours long
you're not watching it straight up in
fact I would say even right when you
pass press play before you even get to
like 5 seconds and you check see how
long it is I think that's a normal
protocol there is a normal protocol you
see two hours you're clicking right out
of there depends on what is and depend
there's not so often that you just got a
two-hour block throw you know sitting a
sitting aside writing those randomly
somebody sent me a video yeah watch it
right now it's not happening yeah
typically doesn't happen like that but
three minutes four minutes
yeah hang with that yeah and you make
sure it with your you know your friend
um yes so subscribe YouTube channel
good way to support also psychological
warfare you don't know what that is is
what it is it's an album with tracks on
this album not music tracks
it's chocolate tracks and these tracks
each track is designated engineered if
you will to help you me so help me is
what it is but it will help you get past
little moments of weakness that you
might encounter
I'm not saying everyone's gonna
encounter it everyone probably will
encounter it but that's not the point
here the point is if you do encounter it
you got something to help you you got
jaakko to help you that's a good deal
you want to skip the workout or
something like this you don't
feel like working out that's really what
it is you don't feel like working out
the comfort of not working out is is C
is distracting you is what it is but
it's it seems more appealing than the
discomfort of working out so what it is
and then you listen to a track there's a
certain track for that how quickly to
you why you should miss the workout boom
partly through the workout you're good
and for every little weakness a you
might come across as a track for it it's
all good just check it out and think
like dang is that one of my weaknesses
boom get it you're good to go
100% success rate in my experience cool
also uh you can get jock a white tee
which I'm not even say anything else
about it because I don't have to because
this is a drink that guarantees an 8,000
pound deadlift and so what up what melts
but where else could I say regardless of
age everyone should know and you should
be careful with that because my
eight-year-old daughter she drank some
chocolate white tea eight thousand
pounds do get something
all right books weigh the warrior kid
you probably already read the first
weigh the warrior kid book if you
haven't you can get that right now
you can also get weigh the warrior kid
to which you have not read yet it's
called demarks mission you haven't read
yet cuz it comes out April 24th it has
more or less ins life lessons how to be
a better human being
how's that for a good subtitle how'd it
be a better human being by the way my
nephew my actual nephew sure he likes
book too better
he liked book one he likes booktube
better judge for yourself preorder it
now wherever books are sold so that it
will be at your door on April 24th when
it comes out and on top of that when you
buy this book you're helping another kid
see this book if that doesn't make sense
like when you buy this book someone else
is gonna see it it's gonna it's gonna
elevate it and other people are gonna
see it we're trying to spread the word
so the more we sell out of the gate the
more kids are gonna hear about this book
and the first book so get a copy for
your kids your neighbor kids your
classroom at school the library
get as many copies as you can because
we're gonna help out a lot of kids get
their lives on the path with this book
if you don't believe me check out Aidan
he's a warrior kid 12 years old own
business you can get his soap Jaakko
soap from Irish Oaks ranch calm so you
can stay clean which is important also
don't forget about this pinnacles
freedom field manual the manual for
getting after it which is what you
should do it's what we should all do how
do you do it though that's the question
and the answer is in the field manual
this political freedom field manual if
you want the audio version it's not on
audible it's on Amazon music google play
other mp3 platforms also extreme
ownership combat leadership applied to
the battlefield to business and to life
number one New York Times bestseller
number one Wall Street Journal
bestseller Amazon bestseller number one
why because it works read it and right
now you can also order the follow-on
book to extreme ownership it's called
the dichotomy of leadership you heard me
talk a little bit about dichotomy today
and in this book life and I go into the
granular principles and examples from
the battlefield and from business that
will make you a better leader and a
better person all those little scenarios
we talked about today if you read them
and understand them you'll be ready for
you when you get punched in the face
with them so pre-order that book now or
you're gonna have to wait that's what
happens if you don't pre-order the book
comes out and you don't get your copy
cuz you hesitated don't hesitate that
book comes out September 25th and if you
need intrusive leadership training with
your team then you need echelon front my
leadership consulting company it's me
Lafe Babb and JP Danelle Dave Burke info
and echelon front com or you can just
visit the website
Ashlin front comm we solve problems
through leadership that's all and of
course there's the muster which is our
leadership seminar would only doing two
years two of these this year
one in Washington DC May 17th and 18th
one in San Francisco October 17th and
18th these events are well on the way to
being sold out that's all there is to it
there's not gonna be any other musters
this year come to one of these we will
be there we will not be hiding backstage
we will be out front with you join us
there
registered extreme ownership calm also
there is roll call
0:01 happening September 21st in Dallas
Texas this is current military law
enforcement firefighters paramedics and
other first responders we appreciate
what it is that you all do every day and
we want to help you do it even better so
one day leadership seminar about leading
in a dynamic environment you can sign up
for that at extreme ownership calm as
well and until we do see you at the
muster at the roll call if there's some
reason that you want to continue this
conversation with us you can find us on
the interwebs at Twitter on Instagram
and inside that fascia poha this you
will find echo who is that echo Charles
and I am at Jocko willing and thanks to
all the military folks that are out
there tonight as some forgotten
barricade waiting and ready for whatever
comes into the police and law
enforcement firefighters EMTs and other
first responders who are here on the
home front also waiting and also ready
for whatever comes thanks to all of you
and to everyone else that is out there
listening but not just listening more
important watching watching yourself
observing yourself looking to see what
you can do better and where you can be
better so that you can become better
keep yourself in check hold the line and
get after it
so until next time this is echo and
Jocko out